If you need a little extra energy or you
need to pay really close attention to
something today,
here's what you should do.
You should make a prediction about
anything.
It can be a prediction of how many
emails you'll get in the next hour,
or it could be a prediction about who's
going to win the baseball game tonight.
It could be a prediction of how many
jumping jacks can you do with 60
seconds.
Make a prediction and then just wait to
see if you were right or not.
Every time that you make a prediction,
you get a little bump of dopamine in the
reward pathways of your brain.
The reason why you get a little dopamine
bomb is that your brain is preparing
itself to learn.
So we,
we often think of dopamine as the reward
neurochemical,
uh,
when there's something we really want,
like,
like a cookie or a pat on the back.
And we get this dopamine hit in
anticipation of it.
So we think about it as being really
related to pleasure and,
and fun and satisfaction.
But the reason why dopamine feels good
is that the brain is actually trying to
trick us into learning or improving our
strategies for being successful or
getting what we want.
So dopamine is going to prime your brain
to pay closer attention,
to process information more effectively,
to be more engaged with what's going on.
And uh,
and,
and so just make a little prediction
about anything.
You'll get the dopamine hit,
your brain will go into high gear and
you could really use this in,
in very strategic ways.
For example,
if you're giving a presentation,
ask your audience at the beginning of
your presentation to make a prediction.
It could be about your presentation,
it could be about something in their own
lives.
You've given them a dopamine hit.
Now they're paying attention.
They're going to actually learn more
from what you're about to say.
So make a prediction.
It's a really easy way to get the
benefits and the learning benefits
specifically of a dopamine bump.
You'll also just feel happier,
which is good too.